over 400 TV shows are broadcast every
year and that means the competition for
viewers is fierce as a result networks
are often willing to spend big money on
projects they think will lure in the
biggest audience they place their bets
and sometimes lose their shirts here are
some of the most expensive TV flops to
ever have their plugs pulled battlestar
galactica most people today know
Battlestar Galactica as the marathon
worthy sci-fi series that ran from 2003
to 2009 hardcore fans however might
remember that the series originated in
1978 and tanked in the ratings a year
later setting out to be a TV take on
Star Wars the original Galactica cost
roughly 1 million dollars per episode
more than doubled that of a typical
primetime show at the time and the
equivalent of over 3.7 million dollars
today at first it was worth the price
tag the series early episodes attracted
positive reviews and healthy ratings but
those ratings eventually began to slip
and behind the scenes issues like
censorship made production difficult
ultimately Battlestar Galactica couldn't
pull its weight as compared to other
less expensive Network gets such as
ABC's own Mork & Mindy and the show was
canceled after a single season the
network did give it another go with
Galactica 1980 but that show only lasted
10 episodes before being decommissioned
due to non-existent viewers supertrain
when it comes to expensive flops you'd
be hard-pressed to find a bigger train
wreck than 1979's super train as you
might expect from the title the NBC show
was basically just love boat meets
snowpiercer
set on a massive nuclear powered
locomotive featuring its own nightclubs
and casinos that could speed from New
York to Los Angeles at 200 miles per
hour the thing is the Train didn't
actually exist so the show's creators
used expensive model trains while
filming
unfortunately the models weren't
particularly durable and one of them was
destroyed in a crash before the first
episode was even filmed after the show
debuted to downright terrible ratings
famous celebrities were brought on to
keep super train on track Tony Danza rue
mcclanahan and Dick Van Dyke all made
guest appearances but even that late 70
star power couldn't stop super train
from going off the rails the show was
cancelled after 9 episodes and remain
one of NBC's costliest flops to date at
a reported four million dollars in
episode father of the pride it makes a
lot of sense that after Shrek raked it
in at the box office NBC was willing to
fork over big bucks DreamWorks for a
computer animated show of their own it
makes a lot less sense that they decided
that the project that would be worth two
point five million dollars of their
money would be a show that recast the
white lions from Siegfried and Roy's
famous Las Vegas magic act as a wacky
sitcom family the result was father of
the prime unlike Shrek which somehow
spawned an unstoppable franchise that we
just can't seem to get rid of it failed
to capture the hearts and minds of those
who watched it it did however capture
plenty of unwanted attention the Parents
Television Council flooded the FCC with
allegations that father of the pride was
indecent to make matters worse the show
came in hot on the heels of Roy being
nearly mauled to death when one of his
Tigers dragged him off stage by the neck
the first such accident in more than
5000 shows with all that stacked against
it
it didn't take long for NBC to make the
show disappear after only 13 episodes
Viva Laughlin when some shows get
cancelled they leave viewers feeling
like they missed out on something good
that never got a chance to shine when
CBS dropped the hammer on 2007's viva la
Flynn however it was a mercy killing
that freed the audience from what the
New York Times suggested might be the
worst show in the history of television
made in an effort to diverge from the
standard lineup of police procedurals
and Grandparent focused sitcoms CBS
banked big on a remake of Viva Blackpool
a popular BBC show with a bizzare
premise a murder mystery that would
occasionally break out into elaborate
musical numbers where the cast sang pop
songs
[Music]
despite the presence of producer and
star Hugh Jackman critics and viewers
alike hated the casino-themed musical
from the opening number its ratings were
dismal and it quickly became a go-to
punch line on the E networks the soup as
a show
beloved by hundreds which might have
been overstating it after only two
episodes
viva la flan danced its way off airwaves
and with the pilot purportedly costing
6.8 million dollars cutting losses early
is probably the right call Camelot as
the first series ordered under Chris
Albrecht the newly crowned president and
CEO of stars hopes were riding high on
2011's Arthurian drama Camelot according
to Albrecht the show was based on quote
an idea of hope that has resonated at
different times throughout history
unfortunately 2011 was not one of those
times critical reviews of Camelot were
less than stellar
but while the show still saw solid
ratings during its final episodes stars
canceled the fantasy drama after only
one season scheduling conflicts with
leaf cast members Joseph Fiennes Jamie
Campbell Bower and Ava Greene made a
sophomore effort more trouble than it
was worth and it was worth quite a lot
according to The Wall Street Journal the
series cost roughly seven million
dollars per episode
that's a Lancelot of money huh look you
can't blame us for trying that one Kings
betting on the star power of Deadwood's
ian mcshane the writing prowess of
American Gods Michael Greene and some
assistance from The Hunger Games
Catching Fire director Francis Lawrence
NBC seemed poised to hit it big with
2009's kings and ambitious drama
reimagining the life of the biblical
King David in a modern setting the
two-hour premiere cost a massive 10
million dollars with each subsequent
episode coming in at four million
dollars upon with that kind of money
behind a television series
you better believe the stakes were high
in this case producers rolled snake eyes
and cashed out with dismal ratings but
Kings wasn't just costly for NBC Liberty
Mutual invested a five million dollar
sponsorship into the show reportedly
aiming to subconsciously piggyback on
the show's message personal
responsibility to encourage viewers to
my insurance with barely anyone watching
the show however it's safe to assume
Liberty Mutual didn't exactly get what
it paid for Kings was first banished to
the dog days of summer before NBC
officially called it quits still the
show isn't as bad as its rating supply
and it might be worth going back if you
missed it the first time around Marco
Polo Netflix is no stranger to dropping
big money on big projects but in the
case of 2014's Marco Polo the series
never really found its way to an
audience and wound up losing big in the
process at the time of Marco Polo's
release no active series was more
expensive to produce
except HBO's fantasy juggernaut Game of
Thrones the first season of Netflix's
Kublai Khan centered drama cost a
staggering 90 million dollars which
weighs in at 9 million dollars per
episode
unfortunately for Netflix Marco Polo
never came close to Game of Thrones
success despite lackluster critical
reviews Netflix gave Marco Polo a second
season the sophomore effort was less
popular than the first prompting the
streaming service to give the series the
axe in this case 13th century mongol
acts
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]